All right, welcome to another Zoom call and reminder, as I do every week, you have questions
that want answered right away.
Look at our blog post on our regular website, so I have a ton of stuff in our new membership
site, and if you're not utilizing that, you're making a mistake.
That's where we're going to have all our announcements, so I'll make announcements
on the weekly Zoom calls, but they're also posted on the main page, the home page of the
patient membership site.
So make sure you look at that, you say, what do we even know what that is.
You have been sent, it's your patient of ours, you have been sent an invite.
So search your email that you use with the clinic for either input or cutters, clinic.com
or a membership, or something like that, and you should find that invite, and you need
to create a password, your username will be your email, your main email, your password
is something you create, if you forget your password, you can just ask it or do password.
But you should be using the membership site.
The membership site is where you're going to see a announcements, so I will make announcements
as new things come up on our Zoom calls, which I'm going to do right now.
So number one, use the members only site to see all announcements, please.
Number two, we added a new Zoom call on Mondays at noon with Ann, next week will be her
first one, see details on the members only site.
It's just a Q&A Zoom call with Ann on Mondays at noon, that's central time, all the details
are on the members only site.
You do register for that, just like you registered for this one, then you'll get email reminders
every Monday or whatever the Zoom sends out their reminders, and you'll get the log in details.
So look at the members site for that, new information.
We don't have a submit questions for Ann, for me, that's something we'll decide whether
we're going to add them.
We also added a page on genetic reviews, we are now doing all these via Zoom call on Thursdays
at 2, so if you did not have your genetic review yet, don't worry, just wait until we tell you
that your genetic information is back, so don't jump on this Zoom call next Thursday at 2.
She's not doing it tomorrow, I think it's the next Thursday, the first one, do not jump on it until
you get your genetics back.
We'll ask you just to jump on it.
So then lastly, there will be no Zoom call next week, I'm going to take a few days off, and
there will be no Zoom call next week, this will be the first Zoom call that we missed.
I think I missed four Zoom calls in five years, do we?
I decided I'd wait to take next week off, so I apologize for that.
You could still send your questions in the next week after that.
A lot of questions came in, so let's get started.
Sorry, I think this was addressed in past Zoom calls, but I can find it.
I am avoiding all sugars and sweeters, my plan also says to avoid sugars.
Our Zylethal and Stevia considered generally included the sugars to avoid less.
Good question.
We haven't had this for a while, so that's why we probably haven't seen it in a recent past Zoom call.
Zylethal is a sugar alcohol.
There's lots of different sugar alcohols in the market.
Now Zylethal would be considered safe for people trying to avoid sugar.
It does not increase your blood glucose levels, so that's a whole idea of avoiding sugars and sweeters.
You know what, it increases your blood glucose levels.
The Zylethal that you do want to look for, though, you want to look for the,
a good organic Zylethal.
A lot of Zylethal are made from GMO corn.
Now, you don't want that at all possible.
Stevia is also a safe, sweeter that's made for the Stevia plant.
You could grow it yourself if you want.
That you also don't want any major name brand Stevia, probably because it's made from GMO.
There's usually pesticides and junk like that on it, so get a natural.
It's natural pop as possible products that your sourcing produce.
Avoiding kale is a common question because I've said it in my book.
I've said it in different things that we don't want to have a lot of kale.
So both green strings have kale listed as a greedy.
It's chocolate flavor has a little bit less maybe listed as last.
I think it probably hasn't saved a mode plan says to avoid chocolate, which is worse chocolate with less kale or no chocolate with build kale.
So where you want to avoid kale, I think I touched on this last week or the week before too.
Why would a person who has cancer want to avoid kale?
Well, you want to avoid boosting nitric oxide levels.
So nitric oxide is something that is really good to boost if you have cardiac problems.
The person has cancer and cardiac problems.
So why wouldn't you boost nitric oxide if you have cancer versus cardiac problems?
Well, nitric oxide does a couple of things.
It can decrease inflammation at the endothelial level in the subendothelial muscle.
So your endothelial are your single cell epithelial cells that lie to all your vessels.
So nitric oxide can be very beneficial as a relaxed to those muscles.
So it could decrease blood pressure.
And also because it opens up your blood vessels, it can be beneficial for electro ED as well for men.
But for cancer patients, it also increases vascular endothelial growth factor.
So it can increase growth factor of vessels, which is really good for heart patients, for cardio patients.
But it's not so really good for a cancer patient because we don't want to increase growth blood vessel growth into cancer.
So this would not be applicable to blood cancers like leukemias, multiple myeloma.
Still would be applicable to lymphomas, but it's mainly for solid tumors that I'm speaking about here.
So avoiding too much nitric oxide.
Now, having a little kale in your salad, having a little kale in your green drinks is just fine.
So that's why we use the greens, drinks.
A little bit of kale mixed with other things, just fine.
It's just that why I put that in my book and why I have a video,
which I spent standing on the videos because a number of years ago was a really big craze.
Maybe it still is to make kale smoothies.
So people are just stuffing kale into a blender and blend it up and just continue to do that or juicing kale because that was very good for cardiac problems.
But it's not having such high concentrations of kale, kale is the highest concentration of naturally occurring nitric oxide is found in kale.
And then it has more than three times the amount of nitric oxide in the same weight of spinach.
It's just you would want to make a kale smoothie with a ton of kale. It's probably too much nitric oxide, but having a little bit of kale in your salad every day, having a little bit of kale in your green drink, you're just fine, you just don't want to overdo kale like
like some groups of natural people did in the past, at least.
Like I said, it was a big craze for a while doing kale smoothies.
So that's why I talked about kale, but having a little bit in your greens is just fine.
That's not the issue.
FYI, I found that there's a rife program for neuropathy in case this helps.
And pity but fantastic, that's great. Hopefully that will help some people.
There's also some neurological programs.
I can't remember the name of it, because I just looked at it today.
There's a neuro program neurodegener, neuro regeneration. I think it's called that would be helpful, I think, too.
There are a phosphatical colline supplement that is not derived from soy that you could recommend.
The alternative that our store has, it's been out of stock for quite some time.
Yes, there is, there is, I think it's phase two, look at it real quick here.
It's the phase 2.5 supplement that has phosphatical colline from another source.
I think it is.
It's the, yes, that's phosphatical colline from sunflower less of them.
That's in a capsule form. So it's phase 2.5.
That is, I'll show you this product right here.
Phase 2.5 bile support that has phosphatical colline that is not derived from soy that might be your best bet.
Some of our products, if you do notice a product on our store that says sold out, make sure you call the clinic and talk to somebody in the store.
Sometimes it's listed as sold out because we just can't get it anymore or the company discontinued it.
And in order to, you know, our web person said don't take it off because it's not good for the store.
So, so make sure you ask about that.
And some things are just on back order.
You have one thing that's on back order until October.
It's just crazy. Some of the things.
There's one product from the one company that we don't use a lot for cancer, but that's been back where it said some last November.
It's still not.
I recently heard the term fairytosis, which I understand is a non-apoptotic form of cell death.
I understand it is an apoptotic form of cell death. It's not a, it's not a, it's not a normal apoptotic form of cell death.
I don't know a lot about barytosis. It's, I think, generally considered a pathological death of a cell.
So, it's not a pathological death of a cell that has gone through apoptosis, but with some different type of blebbing that normal, that's different from normal apoptosis has something to do with different oxidation of the cells in different ways.
I have not heard it to be used as a treatment for cancer, though. So this is interesting. I would have to dig into this.
Please explain this process and the relationship to the other forms of cell death. Well, I can't explain that process. I don't know enough about it yet. Dig into it and learn a little bit about it.
There's one better than the other. So, normal program cell death is called apoptosis. There's multiple different stimulation of apoptosis that takes place.
I actually have to get back to it. I created a whole PowerPoint presentation on it, and then I didn't end up recording it because it was just so technical and deep that I thought, my gosh, we're going to enlist into this.
It's a couple years ago. I saw it about a month ago. I thought, well, maybe I should re-report this.
So I have to look into it. There's different simulations of apoptosis. How apoptosis was normally stimulated from an external environment, being external to the cell.
There's different receptors on your cell membrane that are apoptotic receptors that also function in different ways.
The vitamin D receptor is also an apoptotic receptor. That's why by the way, D can be good for cancer.
This is the different apoptotic receptors are what can be blocked by bad estrogens.
It's not that the estrogen is the cause of a cancer ever. What causes the cancer is something that got inside the cell that affects the replication cycle. That's not what estrogen does.
So when a person has ER positive cancer, the estrogen is not the cause of a cancer, but estrogen, and it's only the bad estrogen, quote, unquote, that gets that attaches to an apoptotic receptor.
They're called the estrogen beta receptors or the A-all receptors that you're still called.
And what it attaches to that receptor, it blocks apoptosis, so apoptosis doesn't take place.
So the idea of removing all estrogens, because they have a drug for it, is you're also removing those quote, quote, bad estrogens.
So I hope you put it up that receptor for apoptosis to take place normally.
It isn't a, it isn't in itself a treatment for cancer, but it helps induce apoptosis or help block the blockage of apoptosis. That makes sense.
I also read that there are maybe repurposed drugs that can induce apoptosis. I don't know what those are.
They may be found at care oncology's site, and that gals work on different reuse and repurposing different drugs. They may find more information there care oncology.
My acupuncturist, who also does IV therapy mentioned that sodium is scorbate as an alternative to glucose derived I dose vitamin C.
So they can be used for IV therapies, you know, much about this alternative.
Not a lot. I do know that it's still synthetic.
Though it may not be glucose derived. I don't know if glucose derived is scoramic acid.
Actually does anything to glucose though, because it's derived from glucose doesn't necessarily mean that it's raising glucose levels in any way.
It's easy enough to check by just checking your glucose levels. I don't believe that that takes place.
The problem that we have posed, the possible problem that we posed about IV vitamin C in the past is that it's synthetic and it's simply a scorbic acid.
The scorbate is just another form of scoramic acid. So that's not really a solve to that problem.
Can't get whole food vitamin C in an IV form that would probably never be possible.
Also, someone is avoided any type of glucose derived high dose C and looking for initial functional support for neuropathy.
Would you recommend any other support of IV therapies without C such as B vitamins?
Well, the B vitamins that are given in IV centers are all synthetic too.
And that's a concern might as well. I think actually the B12 is cyanocombolomy, which is not really good at all.
It may have a hydroxychombolomy, which would be good.
If they're using a methylchombolomy, this is the B12. So chombolomy is B12. It's linked to something.
If it's linked to cyanobolucule, then that's highly synthetic and not recommended.
If it's linked to a methyl group, that's what's typically recommended for non cancer patients, because methyl groups can be people can have deficiencies in methyl groups. So when the MTHFR, genetic slip defect was discovered.
That's was a piece of the genetic complex that takes folate to end up making your B vitamins and methyl groups through through the whole metiety cycle.
Everybody was hot trotted adding methyl groups to their vitamin B. So they changed all their vitamin B complexes to methyl tetrahydrofolate for the folic acid. Well, it's much better than folic acid folic acid is synthetic folate.
And they changed their B12 to methylchombolomy versus cyanolchombolomy or hydroxychombolomy or adenosylchombolomy.
That's all good and great, because if people have a MTHFR defect, they need more methyl groups, but it's not so good and great.
Because as you learn more about genetics, you learn that too much methyl groups, even for someone who doesn't have cancer, drives other pathways.
And one of the pathways that too much methyl groups drives is the biopteran pathway where you make all your neurotransmitters.
So people can, and if you have any type of mood disorders at all, which how many people have that today, you know, with anxiety or depression or OCD or all sorts of different things that we probably everybody probably has some for that to excess methyl groups can drive that pathway.
And get a surge of serotonin that have rage issues and anger issues or surge of dopamine that have different issues or
glutamates that have OCD issues. There's a lot of different issues with that. So I've never been a fan, as you learn more about genetics, you don't just look at one gene defect to treat the person, because you can, you can cause more problems than not.
And then it further gets complicated when you have a diagnosis of cancer, because one of the things that old groups do is they silence genes and we don't want, we want to be careful with excess methyl groups, we don't want to silence our tumor suppressor genes.
Well, I'm sorry to say another big fan of IV vitamins, magnesium is probably fine to have in that, but magnesium is fairly readily absorbed. So I don't know why you want to get it in the IV.
You know, cost of due to IV and getting magnesium, unless you're completely dehydrated and your electrolytes are so off that you need some minerals.
OCD sense of that calcium, there's no way I would get calcium in an IV. Most likely it's a calcium carbonate that could cause vessel gardening that itself could cause cardio issues, I just there's no way people, you know, cancer patients are not typically deficient in calcium.
But more so if they have a test system, they have excess calcium in their blood, and if your calcium levels are normal and you're adding calcium via IV, you're literally throwing out your pH of your body and your body has to deal with that with a whole bunch of different buffering systems taking place.
I will never do calcium in an IV.
Again, you know, amino acids are typically very readily absorbed, and it forms that you would normally receive them in plant-based amino acids, much more than IV.
Besides the fact that some cancers can be driven by amino acids, so I'd be very careful with that.
I've already had parasites, I'm still passing many worms a day, I'm assuming they are passing because their ecosystem is becoming unspinable to them.
So you're getting healthy and data likelihood.
Or is it something I'm taking? Well, probably it's something you're doing. It's just your changing your gut and your changing your body and your helping make them not happy there.
And this can help very much. The right for, if you're running parasite programs, that is the best killer of biotoxins and things that is using the right.
So definitely you know, you want to be utilizing the right for you have parasites run some parasite programs.
How do you know where they're going? You just don't, I mean, you can run a lab for them.
That's probably the best way to know, but still, again, like I've said, with any other tests, there's, you get a lot of false positives of false negatives with tests too.
Probably just better off continuing to do the right things and and let nature take its course that way.
My mom is suffering from an increasing the bad restless leg problem, preventing her from sleeping, keeps her up, she gets up every hour to the bathroom, can't get back to sleep.
It's very difficult. I do have an article on ferritin iron and cancer. So iron deficiency can be an issue with restless legs.
You don't want to take iron if you have cancer, unless you definitely have low iron levels. So getting a blood test is for way to go.
Iron can feed cancer, and that's not good. So if you're going to take iron because you're low, you have low hemoglobin that you have low iron, you really have a deviate, which is very common with cancer, then you want to take something like
that you've tested and or burberryed with cancer because they tend to follow iron and then your, if the cancer is goblet at the air that it'll have to gobble up the art of missing it and
burberryed as well, and that can help kill the cancer. So then you just use it to your advantage, but you do want to get a blood test before you take iron.
Melatonin has it really helped. Melatonin will only help you fall asleep. It won't help you stay asleep or never.
You could take higher doses of melatonin. There really isn't a high limit of melatonin to take so I will try to increase that.
Full spectrum CVD can be very helpful for relaxing. We have a CVD called CVD's pavate sleep that has some nice other cold. We'd herbs in it too. We get a lot of feedback on that that people really like that to help them calm down and sleep.
One of the things that I found with restless leg syndrome is if you can take a bath with epsom salts and lavender.
You can also use a cup of epsom salts and use lavender essential oil, maybe put 50 drops of lavender essential oil in your bathtub and just lay in the back for five minutes.
That's all you need. That can really help calm down restless legs.
It can also be a mineral deficiency not just tired, but it can be a magnesium deficiency. It's the benefit of using epsom salts.
So think about using minerals and minerals can be something that as we age, it's more difficult to absorb minerals and so it's really important that we are looking at minerals.
It's also the heat. If you're out sweating at all, you're losing a lot of your electrolyte. So usually restless leg syndrome has to do with an electrolyte mineral deficiency of some kind.
Is there a true right problem that helps I haven't found I haven't heard any feedback any good feedback of any true right problem that helps rest the slides that's really you have to deal with that deficiency.
Starting by invasive bladder cancer running the true right programs around two weeks ago started and taking suggested supplements just a week ago to discomfort is becoming unbearable.
We watched your video good and bad pain and understand the pain may increase at the start of treatment.
It can be done for the cuts in horrible birdie pain or I'll buy you a restaurant in regions.
So yeah, it's you want to always when you have a symptom, you want to make sure you aren't just treating the symptom that you're making sure that something else you're trying to look for cause right.
So could the paid be because your your body is killing the cancer. Yes, that's always a possibility.
But then you'd have paid right at the cancer site that's somewhere else. So the basic bladder cancer, if you don't have your reason, if it's not spread to the urethra and you have urethral paid, I would say you do want to consider is there a possible infection.
Do you have some sort of UTI that you should treat differently with maybe some different supplements or even medication, making sure that you get that check might want to do a UA with your local doctor and see if there is bacteria present.
But you need to treat or like blood cell elevated or something like that that you want to look for look for a possible look for the possible causes.
There, I know when we have cancer, we always say, well, if the cancer, it's not always the cancer, it can be other comorbidities that are going to.
Now several to write programs for paid, again, I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily run the feed programs, I would rather think about UTI type programs or infection type programs, viral bacterial type programs, that's what I would think.
Although, although I've never tried Boswellian white willow bar has never touched my pain in the past, I'm already taking several that you mentioned the page for like ginger to look at.
I would say that if you're taking ginger and curcumin and stuff and CBD that's not touching the paid, you do, again, want to get to the root of the pain.
And even taking like a paid medication, oh, it makes the pain go away with the pain is a signal or something.
The pain is just because your body's killing this cancer or because the cancer itself, that you can't do anything about tell your body starts killing it and make it decreasing the pain because of that.
Then, then by all means, using a paid medication is the right thing to do because you don't want to attempt to just tolerate pain.
But if your pain is caused from something else and you just take a paid medication, well then you're just overriding your body's attempt to tell you that there's something wrong there.
So do make sure that you get the diagnosis, what is the cause of that.
Recently, I read that Dr. Flavin, who does integrative cancer protocols, she was integrated on the face of cranes missing lead cancer series along with me said that she only approved certain types of selenium supplements as some types could contribute to cancer growth.
So yes, I think you actually got that information from me, but it's selenium the thigh died, which is a very good source.
Selenium is a common source of cal, of selenium for patients with thyroid issues.
But if your cancer is driven through the thigh, then you don't want selenium as a supplement.
So there is liquid selenium that we use, there's other seleniums that are out there.
The selenium middle acid key light, I'm not sure what that is.
But that is typically selenium, I'd have to look and see what the amino acid it's collated with.
So that's that's the thing you have to know if it's just selenium collated with the thiety, the thiety doesn't be the acid, then that's what you wouldn't want to use.
If your cancer is driven by the thiety, well, how do I know if my cancer is driven by the thiety, well, if we took you off of red meat, then you don't want to use selenium, selenium, the thiety, it's usually called.
If well, no, you didn't take you off red meat, then you're safe using it so it's only people whose cancer is driven by the thiety that you wouldn't want to use selenium, that's the only one.
Second note on this is that usually the dosage, how much the thiety you're getting it is letting the thiety to so many is that it's really not an issue to be honest with you.
You're getting much more with thiety in just in just plant proteins that you're getting in a daily dose of selenium.
So I just think this is really a bad issue.
Okay, there's some questions.
If you want to just get off of the sewage all together, then I would do exactly what you're saying, should I increase my intake of the 2.5 and then just drop phase out the 5.
It'll totally look like capsules. Yes, that would be a good good.
I have found so keyed my feet in an inch of magnesium oil like ancient minerals brand. Yes, so there's a brand of mineral oil called ancient minerals.
So we used to sell it, we don't anymore, but you could look it up on Amazon or something like that.
So key in your feet for 10 minutes helps restless legs and ankle cramps magnesium supplements help some too, but you're getting the magnesium right to and this is, this is a good solution for people who like there's no way I could get my mom in a bathtub.
You could also do the only thing I have against the mineral oil is that as it dries, it dries as a salt on your skin because magnesium, all your minerals have to be chelated to something.
So it ends up becoming a magnesium salt as it dries on your skin and it can be itchy.
It's not a big negative. You just got to wash your feet after it dries if it's itchy for you.
We used to use a lot of the magnesium oil because it is fairly well absorbed through the skin.
But that was the complaint that we got people will put all their arms and that's how they're going to apply it or on their belly, but then they say, oh, I got this.
It's just like crazy, well, there's washer arm, but it's just it was just an issue that some people have you can also do.
If you have some salt just in a foot bath too, you could just fill your bathtub and put your feet in the bathtub sitting on the toilet.
If you're toilets right next to your bathtub or sitting on a chair and as you can set next to your bathtub, if you're by yourself, you don't want to get in and out of the tub by yourself.
I started the right last week but said, send me my initial info to your clinic regarding my lung cancer.
I was with a lung infection. I'm sorry. After 22 days of antibiotics, I'm better, but there still seems to be some signs of infection.
Should I add an additional right program to help? Yes, especially if you know if they cultured what that infection was.
Let me explain. So if you're in the hospital with an infection, they said you have, you know, strep infection because they cultured it, then run the strep program it.
So whatever they told you you have, if they gave you the specifics on it, if there's a specific program in the right, look for that, if there is then run that.
If the antibiotics helped with the infection, then it was most likely a bacterial infection. But after 22 days of antibiotics makes me think that it quite possibly could have been a viral infection and the antibiotics were just killing any subsequent possible secondary bacterial infection.
Usually if you have a back straight bacterial infection, you don't necessarily 22 days of antibiotics, but it's possible because of the cancer.
So there are, that means that there are specific programs for specific bacteria. If you can't buy that specific bacterial that they told you listed and run the bacteria programs.
Also, there's a viral complex program, which is, this is about two and a half hours, but really good. So you might want to run that as well. Do those during the day.
So some of the bacterial programs are shorter, maybe 30 minutes, but run them a couple times and cycles through some of the bacterial programs. If you don't know the specific organisms that they said that you will cause it your infection.
So great, great thought process. It brings up another point that you really want to use your right for your first go to on all these things, especially any type of infection.
If anything you can think of, use your right as the first book to, you're sure we say it over and over again that we've had so many testimonials about the right helping people with the absolutely craziest things.
So use the right as your first choice of medicine cabinet, you could say, like you go to your medicine cabinet to take something for this symptom you have, use your right for that and let your family use your right when you're not using it for things that they're dealing with to you can never hurt yourself with the right.
So that's what it should be the first go to doesn't mean you would do other things to but still that should be your first go to.
Is there a program on the right for swollen lymph nodes under my chin? Well, there's program for swelling.
So also, whatever we talked about last week about this, the swollen lymph nodes under your chin that probably coming from dental infection. So run them, always think about, well, what caused that thing.
So by symptom is pain, like we talked about in the question before, well, do I just take something for pain? Well, you should first ask, what's my pain from.
Just like if I am a toothache, do I just take a Tylenol, make my toothache go away, or do I have to go and fix what's causing my toothache? Well, of course you would right same thing with anything though, sometimes we get the habit of just treating the symptom we have to make sure we're always thinking about cause.
So swollen lymph nodes, yeah, you could run the swelling program, but better baby is, okay, why would there be swollen lymph nodes underneath my chin? Well, that it's like the live chain underneath my mandible is my somewhat bendivular lymph node chain in that drains all my dental, all my sinuses, all my face from my head.
So could be an infection or inflammation from somewhere upstream. So then you think, okay, if it's an infection, remember, that's another one cause of swollen lymph nodes, then maybe it's a dental infection. So maybe I should run the dental infection programs. There's a whole bunch of dental programs that would be good to run.
Maybe running the viral program again, like we said, maybe running some bacterial programs by were you with this I've run dental programs and maybe the viral program.
Very, very welcome. Any other questions. So remember the announcements.
You can see them on your screen there. So I won't reread them, but are there any right programs or helps for pain and swelling that happens in the process of.
Okay, so you got to do the black sad process. There's pain and swelling that can happen from that right. So now you know the cause. So it's because the citizen skin is stretching.
And you're cleaning it with hydrogen peroxides. You really know there's no infection.
So now that I would just find the the pain or the pain programs or the swelling programs. So exactly think through that process.
How you would, you want to look for cause. Oh, this is the cause. I already know what that isn't about treating that. Well, then now you could just treat the symptoms.
Question and this a question in my AFP question.
I didn't see that question. If you ask that.
Well, I can look on the website regarding earlier sugar post about monk fruit. So monk fruit is another commonly used sugar substitute.
But I do believe monk fruit raises glucose levels. So it's a natural source of sugar, but it doesn't it's not necessarily a substitute for it doesn't decrease your.
It doesn't not raise blood glucose levels.
So yeah, you can use it, but you'd want to still be careful with the amount that you're using because it's raising glucose levels.
Okay, I'm looking at our site right now. Oh, there's a question.
Here's the question. I have five to a marker tests done monthly AFP at all the CA tests. AFP is the only one that has ever been out of range. Thank God.
If I have breast cancer and AFP measures for a variant liver cancer, is there any reason to think I have liver cancer or a very cancer?
No. So the tumor markers are not exactly specific to a type of cancer.
So AFP is tends to be elevated more so with people with liver or a very cancer, but you could have stage four or a variant or a liver cancer and you still have normal AFP levels.
So none of this is a perfect sign. So no, if you have a tumor marker test that's typically for something that other than you have it is not suggest that you have another cancer.
You certainly want to look at other signs and symptoms before you leave from close to jumping back kind of thing.
But the high range number for breast cancer patients, AFP result that I don't know. There's no data on that. Sure. So it's they just have a normal range that is given us the lab level range.
And so there's a high number for breast cancer with that.
So again, you know, so your other cells give off these these tumor marker enzymes, you know, so it's that's why there's a range. So maybe the normal range for something is zero to 35 and you're at 14 so you're within a normal range.
Hey, well, you're still at 14 of the CA 15 three or whatever and that what does that mean? Well, it means a person can not well that doesn't have cancer still creates those enzymes.
It's just that if a person has cancer, a cancer can create an excess amount of those enzymes and therefore you can use it as a marker. That's why they're called tumor marker tests.
But if you have your daughter who doesn't have cancer, go run those tests. They're going, they're not going to be zero. Your body normally makes some of those things normally. So the truth is is that the elevated AFP in your case may not even be due to the cancer just might be normal for you. So, um,
that's just the truth. So we just don't know. So that's where you say the tumor marker test can be a good indication of growth or regression, but it's if they're again like any test that's certainly not perfect.
Sorry, this question. All right. Well, we will say goodbye to everybody and I won't see you next week. Remember, no zoom call next week. So, um, don't forget, and then we'll see you the week after, but keep submitting your questions on the member site and we'll get to those the week after you have any other needs. Make sure you give us a call.
All right. Thanks so much. I'll be praying for all of you and appreciate your prayers for us to bye bye.